welcome back to New rockstars Deadpool 3
has recently confirmed that the
Wolverine to have a major role and
Marvel studios's first stab at the Merc
with the mouth and the guns and the
swords and whatnot but what if I told
you that these two are already in
serious trouble with the law before they
even stepped their murderous toes in the
MCU this is Rogue Theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is Mt
and growing well with me today is
Professor Xavier's long lost son on the
show of with us today it's Tom
Michaelson what's going on Tom hello
just call me Tom Xavier let me roll
around I already got my head shaved here
we go
hello everybody thanks for having me
back so excited to talk Deadpool
Wolverine X-Men NXT stock X-Men I'm game
dude let's do it it's mutant season
mutants are coming lunch let's go and of
course we have also been blessed with
the presence of the pilot who flew the
plane the the X-Force jumped out of in
Deadpool 2 before they all were
immediately killed it's Brandon Barrick
what's going on Brandon yes and I would
like to say that their deaths do not
fall on the pilot okay
getting on the plane they were safe when
they left the plane
responsibility
they all signed a waiver okay it's all
good we don't blame you except for maybe
thank you um uh the guy that got chopped
up in the wood chipper uh but then again
that was probably that leads us to our
first topic of today I believe that
Wolverine Wade Wilson Deadpool himself
and cable will be arrested by the time
variance Authority at some point very
soon because here's why and you guys
probably know why these three have
messed around with time so badly in
their Universe like my goodness uh
freaking Wolverine during Days of Future
Past like went from his timeline to the
80s or whatever and he just messed up
the flow of time and messed up the uh
The Sentinel program and all that and He
restored the X-Men timeline he literally
fixed Fox's very complicated X-Men
timeline before they would go on to ruin
it themselves
[Laughter]
um my goodness uh but it also Deadpool
and cable in uh Deadpool 2
um they literally just went to town like
they used cables time machine to just
change everything and I I think that
this is going to have serious effects in
their Universe I think the TVA is not
particularly happy with their actions
because Deadpool is a chaotic element
just like Loki is and I think that um
they're all going to be in trouble for
what they did and they they will be
meeting a Mobius and a B15 and all the
wonderful gents and uh gals and um all
sorts of people in the TVA what do you
guys think about this I mean it
certainly makes a lot of sense there's a
lot of time Shenanigans going on and if
we believe that every Universe has a TVA
uh that they would be looking in on it I
think
um and also like the the time traveling
that Logan does right and dates the
Future Past it is very like kind of
mysterious and what we know now about
timelines like that creates like a
branch timeline right the time where
like Logan gets to live happily with the
X-Men in the mansion
that's like separate from like the rest
of the that X-Men crew right right
exactly because I don't think the events
of X2 on happen after uh Days of Future
Past because like we see uh great she's
alive and young seller all of a sudden
is part of the crew now so yeah that's
again right yeah but is that is that
Logan that gets to live in that happy
timeline is that the Logan that dies
that we see die in Logan or is that a
different Wolverine that we see die in
Logan I I think the Wolverine from Logan
is different because um we know from
that movie that mutants haven't been
born for 25 years and that's around 2004
in that um universe so I think that that
universe is like unique for because of
that particular thing that um mutants
were not able to be born so I'm assuming
that it's a different variant but who
knows at this point maybe you know
what's interesting is uh if this uh this
Theory would mean that the X-Men movies
and all that jacked up continuities in
the sacred timeline or some sort right
some some something that means that it's
it's bonify but it's funny to think that
the MCU now is so powerful that they can
fix the continuity of the fox movies
that's just hilarious to me that if
that's how they go around doing this but
no I think this is great uh it's
interesting that with this whole
Wolverine excitement I feel so bad for
uh Josh Brolin he doesn't know why him
he doesn't care but uh he but this whole
time I was like yeah Deadpool wolf
Wolverine I totally forgot cable wasn't
the second one and that's a big deal so
when you said yeah and Cable's gonna
come along I was like oh [ __ ] that's
right
to me I'm just like oh assistant have
Wolverine and Deadpool and a time card
like flying through the Universe I just
thought that it was gonna be something
straightforward like that but no that's
true like it makes sense that not only
would Kate will be hanging around but of
course again the mcu's so powerful now
they can introduce the TVA and just fix
everything every problem we've ever had
with the fox movies also definitively
kill that universe and then bring the
good parts that we like over just like
they're doing with Netflix
basically I mean like and I honestly
feel like
um the the TVA that the fox Universe has
is completely different from the TVA
that we saw for the majority of Loki
because I feel like the TBA that Loki
went to at the very end of the series
could be the fox Universe TVA and um
that's the reason why um you know the
actor that played um
um classic Loki was the uh the villain
of
um Logan and I feel like the reason why
they can be sort of like double like he
can be both people is because he is
playing a different version of like he's
playing a different character completely
in that separate Multiverse batch like
there's a completely new Multiverse um
the completely separate Multiverse and
that's the fox Multiverse and I feel
like Loki's there he's like oh [ __ ] time
to go meet a Hugh Jackman Wolverine and
stuff and go see this complicated
timeline
um and hopefully pick up x23 because I
really want her oh yeah I was hoping she
would jump along um she's fantastic so
that's interesting because in in Loki
the idea is that there is one TVA but
but now that we're merging movie studio
universes you you think that there's
multiple tvas yes I think that's a
multiple sacred timelines basically and
I feel like you know we see at the
beginning of um Loki the Loki finale we
see two black holes I think that the
black hole that we zoomed into that's
the MCU Multiverse sacred timeline the
black hole on the left I feel like is
the fox
um Universe where like they have their
own timeline and then Mobius is like I
don't know who Tom Hiddleston is even
though I'm supposed to be a Loki expert
I've never seen this man in my life
because there's no Tom hillston Loki in
the fox Universe
um so I have a feeling that that's
what's going on there and that um that
TVA is going to be arresting Wolverine
Deadpool and cable for being bad boys
with the time they did let them I mean
at the time the team that TVA let them
do their time Shenanigans you know much
like the 616 TVA allows the Avengers to
jump through time because it was all
part of that story now like remember the
616 TVA its purpose was not necessarily
to keep time safe it was to keep the
other kangs out like every move was made
to keep other kangs out they don't care
what happened inside as long as like
that's why Thanos is allowed to do his
stuff that's why the Avengers are
allowed to do their stuff because it's
all keeping the Kings out uh but now
that's off the table right and the Kings
can come in that means other people can
come in I love this idea Mt because it
would be great for a way to be like
arrested and then just kill everyone in
the TVA and be like okay thank you and
I'll reduce your machine to go over to
the 616.
yeah yeah and you're right you're right
Tom like the MCU is too powerful uh and
I think that's a lot of what secret Wars
is going to be about it's like you guys
are creating incursions across the
you're wiping out other universes like I
love the idea that the MCU is destroying
the fox universe and so that's why Wade
Wilson Deadpool is like we gotta get out
of here I'm gonna take Logan with me
we're getting out of here baby because
this universe is about to be destroyed
uh until they imagine them riding like
the by Frost with this like with the
shrinking world
We're not gonna make
it yeah it's a ship full of like the
best characters from the fox universe
that everyone loves yeah they're getting
taken out or not yeah yeah yeah that'd
be so great the guy Oscar Isaac
apocalypse he's like trying to catch up
and they're like yeah
sorry speed up sorry
the aliens from uh I don't know uh
what's it called Dark Phoenix like
please oh yeah yeah oh yeah or whatever
the [ __ ] we're called
the block or something yeah who knows it
like that but I love I also hope that
and you're there there's a scene where
like every movie ends like in uh Days of
Future Past
um Trask or uh not the trash or over the
back uh no was it
um
whoever's eyes his eyes turned and
became Mystique was that the character
task or no was that it was one of those
Brian Cox was that the Brian Cox younger
version character I'm like Striker thank
you it was Striker's eyes as Mystique so
they're already changing and then that
ends up being nothing the next movie or
what ever that'd be funny if they have
an extra scene now for every movie where
the minutes the minute the credits roll
we get to stay at for another second and
TVA agents show up they charge up and
prune everything so that way they just
that's how they can explain how
everything nothing matters Everything's
changed everybody just gets pruned
immediately when the credits hit for us
like in that end credits of the dark I
mean of Apocalypse with Mr Sinister
being teased they just put a little time
bomb on that briefcase
[Laughter]
at the end of Deadpool 2 when he's going
through time and like you know killing
Ryan Reynolds and killing like his the
original version of Deadpool Wade Wilson
uh he also it ends with him in the
hospital where a young Adolf Hitler has
been born and he is reaching into the
crib to kill a baby
the classic time Paradox now if he's
allowed to do that if the TVA doesn't
stop that then in theory you have a
world it all it would have destroyed his
own Universe right because if you don't
have a baby Hitler who grows up to be
Hitler and then in theory if World War
II doesn't happen the same way it
happens yeah then that prevents like the
Cuban Missile Crisis which started X-Men
first Class right which is where they
all came to a head even more it prevents
the Nazi camps yeah yeah there you go
yes Magneto's history it prevents so
many any problems oh my God it almost
could be that like we could start
Deadpool 3 in that hospital as he's
reaching down and like Logan shows up
doing his own time travel thing and he's
like hey buddy I got I gotta stop you
from doing it hey Mom yeah right there
hey Bobby yeah this little baby
he's just like just just do it just do
it really he's like no no just just do
it got a hot damn time machine this
I never thought about it that like that
is such a good point like Hitler is sort
of centric to the to the thoughts
yeah you know but we kind of we kind of
I mean this don't clip this out please
but we kind of moving you don't even get
you don't get Captain America no you
don't get back to the trailer the
trailer of Deadpool 3 ends with the him
through the camera being like we gotta
save Hitler
hurry we got
that would be the worst slash best movie
ever that is such a very much a
deadpool-esque plot that like I can see
it happening so he's happy so the movie
is him undoing the the killing of Hitler
because if there wasn't that we want to
get capped wouldn't get exactly Magneto
you get to that Paradox they had in Rick
and Morty right where it's just people
keep showing up and killing each other
who are trying to stop the birds
yes it's just portals just opening up
that was always my problem with the
Terminator movies it should just be
constantly people showing up at the same
time to kill and stop each other and
just like yeah body's just piling up
everywhere of like jumping through time
wait so uh correct me if I'm wrong but
like the end of Deadpool 2 ends with him
using the time machine to save his wife
right yeah he goes back to save his wife
yes and he's like we're gonna name our
children after share uh because of that
time
do you think that the TBA would like
want to like arrest her and like maybe
prune her because like oh that that's a
really good one too well that is a good
question Mt and we need to know what the
purpose of the that TVA is like if their
purpose is really protecting some sort
of sacred timeline then yes they might
have to but if she's critical for the
success of that secret timeline then
they would allow her to continue I would
imagine but just just Deadpool jumping
through time would have created so many
Branch timelines
so many things to fix you know I love
that theory that actually a little
theory about his wife though because I
think at the end of the day this
whatever the story is going to be it's
gonna it's gonna have to be a very
personal story I think that's what you
know it seems like that's what speaks to
the character for Ryan Reynolds and both
Deadpool movies ended up being very a
very small story like about him and him
and his wife getting together in the
first one yeah him you know F is for
family and saving that kid
um I mean it became the really small
stories at the heart so that that
actually I think really makes a lot of
sense if it's about him protecting her
now because also that was the thing I
missed from part two is that Miranda
bakarin had barely a role in Deadpool 2
and she's great yeah so if they expand
her role in this sense where now yeah
that they're the fox TVA is after her
and so Deadpool's having to stay one
step ahead to keep her safe and save her
and then yeah and then she'll be in that
car on the bifrost riding on that portal
closing that would be great actually I
really like that yo I think it'd be
really cool if um Deadpool's wife
um becomes uh the MCU personification of
death and like that's why like Thanos
and Deadpool have the right words
because like Thanos loves death and then
like uh Deadpool loves dancers like hey
like that's my wife that you're liking
what like well obviously when nathaniels
would have to come back from the dead
which like I think I honestly feel like
Thanos is gonna come back from the dead
with an obsession with death because he
died before so he's like oh yes I love
Deb and they're introducing that new
Thanos at Disneyland right there's like
looks like Josh Brolin so yeah they're
they are introducing a semicannon an
actual Josh Brolin Thanos that's coming
back so yeah totally so weird to think
that Thanos was just like shaving his
hair the entire time and you could just
grow very long that's embarrant well we
saw some stubble didn't it yeah
every morning he was that helicopter
blade to like yeah
it's like yeah two blade
at his head he actually has a full log
head of hair he shaves that too yeah
that would be like he just has like a
Brandon head of hair yeah
all right but also Tom and Mt dude so
that's why he uses that yeah
all right guys so it's voting time what
do you guys think about this theory of
Wolverine Deadpool cable and potentially
um I forget her name Deadpool's
girlfriend wife I'm so sorry for being
super this is
the actor right wait she's also Vanessa
you better watch out yeah yeah that's
true
I
think it's Vanessa oh they're they're
shouting in the comments right they are
they're like how dare you how dare you
exactly all girls okay yes but what do
you guys think of this theory of
Wolverine Deadpool and cable potentially
being arrested by the time variance
Authority rogus bogus or ogus you know
empty I think I I gotta say I gotta
admit it I gotta admit when I'm wrong
and you're right it's very rogus I don't
sound the wrong you're right here you're
very robust on this okay it's a theory I
was cooking in my own brain that like
the TVA is gonna show up and deal with
this guy uh they gotta deal with it
somehow well I purposely haven't thought
about it at all so this is great so when
I'm here hearing it I'm like oh these
are great ideas so yeah I'm gonna give
this major rogus because again you
reminded me that cable exists which I'm
embarrassed to say I forgot
and you made me think about the the Fox
TV because again yeah the the secret
timeline and the TV like time is
different than Dimensions so of course
in another Dimension they'd have their
own maybe TVA or not TVA you know and so
I think that's that's really those are
really fun ideas again that showcase how
the MCU is so powerful they can fix uh
you know retrospectively the the fox
universe so Rogue yeah man like Kevin
feige like he was working on the uh the
X-Men films back in the day so like yeah
he's well familiar with that universe so
like and all the plot holes exactly yeah
that can really do the job honestly
exactly but thank you guys thank you for
the double rogus I'll take it but up
next Brandon has a really interesting
theory that he's going to be sharing
with us soon but I'll be sure to head on
over to new rockstarsmerch.com where you
can grab our newest latest Obsession
shirt Lady Justice inspired by the
She-Hulk series you can also check out
our latest Obsession shirt Ash and ruin
inspired by the house of the Dragon
series both of these shirts are limited
edition and won't be available for much
longer so be sure to grab them while you
can support the channel and head on over
to new rockstarsmerch.com today but I
guess this leads us to our second topic
for today which will be presented by
Brandon take it away Brandon here here's
here's the deal folks okay I've been
watching She-Hulk been loving She-Hulk
it's it's it's very interesting
especially to see the the MCU through
like a comedic lens uh and how that
affects the world in a weird way and it
really pushes what happens in the
reality of that world in an interesting
way but one thing that is really
sticking with me is like you know we're
having they're just very casually
introducing all these other powered
individuals right people with powers we
saw this week uh at The Retreat right
and these people are doing things
they're getting arrested uh they're
committing crimes and we don't get in
the MCU films and a lot of the shows we
don't see a lot of like what's happening
boots on the ground what are people
dealing with but for the most part
Society seems pretty uh non-plussed
about these like uh Immortal beings or
or you know all this other stuff going
on now granted the MCU
general public has been through a lot
right
alien invasions they've had secret
countries
every week and sokovia falling yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so a man who through an
experiment was turned into a half-man
half bull not not exciting right like
foreign
exactly but why why are they so okay
with it and here's what I think has
happened folks I think that when the
blip
happened the reverse snap whatever you
want to call it when everyone came back
I think the world was fundamentally
changed I think reality was changed in a
way that all these a lot of people came
back with abilities and Powers but
everyone there doesn't know that the
change happened and they assume this is
how it always was this is kind of like
um a Back to the Future right where like
when Marty and Back to the Future too he
goes back to 1985 and everything's a
mess and he's like this isn't the world
I left and all those people are like
this is the world what are you talking
about I think that's what's happened
here I think everyone came back half the
population came back
and a lot of powers were put into people
and they assumed that they were always
there or they don't remember a time
before I think their minds were changed
uh and I think I don't know if the
celestials did this I don't know who did
this but someone introduced all these
Powers into people and this is when they
did it a little uh what does Ant-Man
always say like distraction right or uh
yeah misdirection this misdirection yes
boom while this crazy thing is happening
on going on some some upper being was
like this is when I'm gonna put all this
these Powers into people this is why I'm
gonna put the X gene into people this is
what I'm gonna like do all this change
now that might just be Kevin feige but
that still counts okay
yeah I think I think this is going to be
revealed later that that they something
happened when everyone came back that
fundamentally changed our genetics uh
the reality of the MCU bro this sounds a
lot like House of M dude and like that
makes me
did something on the side like we didn't
see it and like people just have powers
and this one that I love this is such a
good idea yeah we don't have to go that
far maybe when she did the hex when she
undid her hex or whatever maybe that
even could have jump started something
well we were thinking that like during
the show right there was a lot of
theories during one division like oh
this hex is gonna especially with Monica
passing through it and her like giving
her powers or unlocking her powers in a
way we we kind of thought like oh and
this goes out it might do that and we we
kind of had these theories too post end
game when they showed like oh you do the
snap like it sends out these power this
like radiation field and maybe that's
changing People whatever yeah but yeah
it could it could have been Wanda Mt
because like she was snapped away but
maybe even when she came back and she
was reconstructed like maybe that just
Unleashed something of like the uh the
Mind Stone nature within her right that
like just kind of like changed things
for everybody I don't know but yeah I I
do think the the snap the the unblipping
was like a cover for like oh something
else happened behind the scenes that we
didn't see uh and they're gonna reveal
it later what if like everyone that came
back
um got powers But like everyone who came
back was actually transported from a
different Universe where like Powers
were like normal so when they came back
they got swapped or something like that
yeah it's like I don't notice that I'm
on a different planet so whatever like
this is just like Earth 616a right
like everything's the same except for
the powers and they just kind of swapped
like that I don't remember empty do you
remember if they confirmed if Kamala
Khan was was blipped or her family or
anyone in her family I don't know I
think there might have been like a
subtle hint but like I don't remember
well I think I think some either like
the writer or the directors of the show
maybe commented on it on some point I
don't remember I think they did answer
the question
but a lot of people a lot of these
showrunners are like I don't want to
answer I don't want to tell you they're
like yes no whatever you want it's like
listen I they asked me to make a show I
made the show I don't know I had to
write six hours of Television I don't
got time to figure out all this minutia
yeah yeah there's 50 characters on this
show I'm not going to tell you which
ones data did not step away who cares
move on with your lives
answer this question about Iron Man 2
and it's like I'm not even making that
what are you talking about yeah that's
what all the fans want I think these are
the interesting Brandon and it's funny
as you were just setting it up I was
like oh you're gonna say you're gonna
say and then you said XG and I was like
you know the because they need I don't
know how they're gonna do it but they
need to explain why there's been no
mutants either this is a brand new thing
which is gonna be kind of weird because
then you don't get the Magneto origin
story in a sense or even apocalypse
where you talk about mutants have been
here and I've been part of humanity
evolving if it's new it's not that's not
gonna work but then if it's oh old that
it's something's been ingrained in in
the 616 and why has it not come up are
you just gonna say that you know Bruno
uh you know koala's friend just needs to
look at everybody through an iPad and be
like oh you got a mutation
this whole time too uh you had a
mutation you don't have a mutation you
know what I mean like what what what
what's that acceleration gonna be so if
you if you say that it's some kind of
continuity fix like that where with a
House of M type situation where
everybody comes back everything's
different but nobody knows that's really
that's really funny because that would
in a quick one sentence fix that
situation you know and fix that
explanation as to why it would be
interesting I've been around yeah
because I don't want like an old Magneto
walking around being like I was in in a
tournament camp and it's like how old
are you magnesium
at the park and then it moves and he's
like how come it moved I've never had
powers up until now but oh no okay it
would be fascinating to like start yeah
right now and be like oh this is my son
Eric lyncher and you're like oh watch
out exactly
exactly he's like my daddy survived
World War II and just keep it the same
yeah yeah yeah it's just Michael
Fassbender for no reason just like yeah
and he's like I'm 92 years old
today yeah right
it's like I manipulated the iron in my
blood and so I don't age like you know
they could probably do that I don't know
but no I honestly feel like you know the
snap is like this huge Cosmic
radioactive event that happened in like
it hasn't happened twice well three
times right because that'll snap once he
snapped to destroy the stones and then
Hulk brought everybody back so there's
been three ways before there's four
because there's the original there's
What hulk does there's what Iron Man
does the destruction
the universe has been hit with these
things yeah exactly
if Monica got that messed up going
through one hex imagine everybody going
through four waves yeah Infinity sounds
snaps that is very very significant I
feel like those three snaps bro like
that is that's no that's not nothing and
I feel like you know mutants could
definitely come from the snap for sure
and it might also explain why like Jen
Wright can break the fourth wall yeah
the snap shattered the fourth wall yeah
that's why Wade Wilson will be able to
do it also was Jen snapped was just
gonna tell me a general answer the
questions we need to know the people
need to know was Jen was was pug snapped
someone tell me I think that's why uh
Josh wanted to download her phone it's
like I need to know if she was snapped
on the contents of her phone well all
right guys what do we think about
Brandon's theory about the mutants being
tied to the snap and like potentially
coming like just like having their
reality just completely shifted from the
snap what do you guys think you know
I'll I'll be honest I was at first I was
like ah this might be August because
it's kind of yeah it makes sense but but
but when you talked about a way to
introduced the mutant X-Men oh I'm game
I guess you know long time Die Hard
X-Men fan I've been waiting for them to
be introduced and and uh and every
little they're giving us morsels here
and there like with uh you know Xavier
in the 838 and then yeah Bruno the iPad
calling them out then you know I think
that this could be a way to this could
be really a really good uh intuitive way
to do it that doesn't have to have some
like X Mock and a thing x mark and I
know
some other things other things show up
and just explain it all of a sudden you
know
um I I so I I'm gonna give this rogus I
like that it also it also fixes a lot of
other things like maybe She-Hulk yeah
the fourth wall break maybe it broke all
those walls maybe that's why all these
super power people are showing up and
it's you know NBD for everybody so rogue
good job Brandon no I will also give
this a rogus because like I just I like
a good it's like a crazy thing that
happens and like just like in reality
just shifting and like nobody noticing
it's like oh yeah because like literally
there were no mutants there were no
those super powered people like super
power people that were existing in the
MCU prior was like
um like the extremist people I think
that's basically it like that it wasn't
even natural right it was like they were
given that stuff they were giving it
from um Killian so like this is just
it's just so random and I feel like the
snap had to just change reality and I
love yeah I'll just say I love that part
about how we've you know this universe
has experienced so many snaps because
some other universes probably never even
got one snap but in the 616 because of
the way things went down we got so many
that I love that explaining part of the
two sorry I don't know GMT no no no you
told me like that's no that's so true
because like this was the that was the
only reality where the Avengers
succeeded like they failed in every
other reality so like every other
reality didn't get as much snaps as um
616 did so like that is very true and
very unique for um in the Multiverse um
but that was also gonna say like just to
the the point of a Magneto uh the time
Stone was also a part of The Infinity
Gauntlet so like the snap could
potentially radiate throughout time as
well
um yeah the time zone was involved so
like Magneto could be Magneto because of
the snap that happened in the future
which is kind of weird to think about
but like who knows
um comic books can do anything really
but no I want to give this a rogus
myself
um because it's super Rogan I love it
it's so smart Brandon we love you
but now it is time for our Rogue
question are you guys ready for this one
I'm ready do it I'm ready okay because
now that Deadpool 3 has a release date
and confirmed the appearance of Hugh
Jackman as the Wolverine man what is the
wrongest thing that you would like to
see Deadpool do now that he is MCU
Cannon uh it's tough I've got torn
between like two things I really want to
see okay I'm gonna give you both of
these I'm going to take I'm going to
double dip for this okay one is I got to
see Deadpool interact with Kevin feige
like it's gonna happen
he can ask can I find all these
questions like answer this Iron Man 2
question Kevin yeah
I want him to be like why did it say
eight years later in yeah
why is Tony friend of Elon Musk
hey that was the past we all liked him
back then yeah I want Kevin to be like
meet Deadpool and then also be like I
gotta get rid of this guy and go like
hire Ryan Reynolds to kill Deadpool he's
like listen you gotta take care of this
guy but I also want to see what I really
want Deadpool to do as he's doing this
making his way to the MCU I want him to
like break into like the animated X-Men
universe and like grab like an animated
Wolverine and take him to Roger Rabbit
style and have like kind of like how you
have like spider ham in the so like yeah
across the spider verse to see like a
cartoon character living and breathing
in the MCU and they just have to like
deal with that and be like here's the
animated imagine Deadpool and two
Wolverines yeah one animated one movie
The Animated one who never stabs anybody
and always you know throws people
because it's a cartoon and he can't kill
people versus like Wolverine they're
like trying to run away from them and
like close doors but he can just like
slide right between because yeah
and then you can even get Logan you
could get Logan Old Man Logan I mean the
one that actually Cuts people down so
you got the original huge active one
that doesn't draw blood but still stabs
people well that's hilarious Wolverine
no adamantium home there we go let's get
that three three Wolverines yeah that's
great
so I I uh this is semi-cheating because
uh like years ago on a rogue Theory we
talked about what we wanted to see and
so I'm gonna pull that one back out
uh but I I was hoping or I would think
it'd be hilarious if they did this has
got also a little a little bit of
cheating but like Brandon I'm going to
say a couple of things but they're all
related so uh if they do uh thanks
Brandon if they do like uh I want them
to do like a greatest hit to the MCU and
have Deadpool traveling to all those
moments and using his either like slide
device and you know he could bring
Wolverine with him and and then you
could start explaining a lot of things
that we hadn't seen and like maybe he
could be the one to give taser face the
name and make him make him think that
that was a good name you're like no man
taser face is badass look he got a guy
with a place you should do it too I was
like really and then you can have him
just do all these things in the MC that
maybe were not explained he spells he
spells a bunch of acid he spills a bunch
of acid on like uh roady's face when
he's Terrence Howard yeah yeah
you're good right you're good okay okay
yeah you're good yeah that looks the
same right but it could be just him
hitting up all like almost like a
greatest hits album just hitting up like
places like a clip show and then he's
Defenders Dead game because yeah there
you go exactly Dead game and it could
just be him traveling through all that
and it kind of ties in in terms of like
maybe the Multiverse now because at that
time when I when we was talking about
this we didn't know where that we end
game I don't think was out or I don't
know what but anyway we didn't know
where that but we didn't know about the
Multiverse and stuff like that we didn't
even know we were just babies yep we
were just innocent babes but no I really
like this idea of um Deadpool going
through the most like the timeline
Greatest Hits because like I just want
to see the MCU deadpoolified to the
maximum so that'd be a great way to like
really just introduce the character and
be like hey what do I miss like maybe
maybe he went and put all the Easter
eggs around like an Iron Man one he's
like let me put this broken cap Shield
here right you know like let me go do
this let me go do and so he's the one
who's been putting the Easter eggs to be
like oh these nerd boys are gonna love
this yeah or whatever it is I think that
you could weave him into every movie in
a very funny that would be almost
organic way and even even though there's
not too many loose ends in the MCU there
are and he can tie up some of those too
no I love this I'm gonna give you the
Rogue question trophy of the day even
though these were both great great uh
answers I'm gonna share mine with
Brandon because I really want to see
animated uh the voice actor yeah I would
love to see the animated Wolverine in
the movie I I want it so bad I I also do
want to see Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe at some point rather it's like
animated in a special what if Episode we
gotta see that we've got to see that
yeah so I was thinking he might be
Deadpool kills the fox Marvel universe
that was my other thing is that maybe
the movies will be him going around
killing off the Fantastic Four like you
know all the properties he'd kill the
cloud Galactus cloud and it would just
say that way he could be the one you
know wiping his hands Cleveland all
right let's go to the MCU all right yeah
it's like all right we are good we're
good here we're good here at no more
branches okay cool but that is it for
this episode of Rogue Theory I want to
thank Tom Michaelson and Brandon Barrick
for joining us this episode please
follow them on all their various social
medias and please do not forget to check
out your rockstarsmerch.com so you can
buy all of our awesome merch over there
including our latest Obsession shirts
that are only here for a limited time
and if you got some some of our Rogue
theories you can share them on our
Discord if you're over 18 search for the
new Rockstar Discord server and just
join the conversation today we'd love to
have you follow me at Mass retainment
following the rockstars on all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our YouTube channel here on YouTube we
love you guys thank you guys for
spending time with us and getting going
rogue and we'll see you guys next time
bye bye clip
foreign
[Music]